Meghan Markle and Harry now again this
shows what happens when we have a
female-led relationship
um for those of you that don't know
Meghan Markle basically convinced Harry
to leave royalty can you imagine like
I think I'm like sometimes these women
should give classes because like it's
like some chicks can't even get their
guy to like help with the dishes this
woman got her guy to leave his family
now obviously that's that's a terrible
thing we don't want that but I was just
thinking I'm like this girl
like how the hell what did she do to
like deserve this anyways
like she's cute but
she's not like you know she's cute but
it's not like
you know anyways anyways essentially she
convinced Harry to leave the royal
family she cried about the racism and
the sexism and blah blah blah and now
there are rumors that there's a new
report and this is all a legend that
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle are
taking time apart from the marriage
according to a radar online report
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle are
currently taking time apart to rebuild
their relationship after family drama
caused a rift in their relationship a
source close to the couple told the
Tabloid that personal as well well as
cultural differences have caused the
couple to drift apart Harry doesn't fit
in in Megan's tacky Tinsley Tinseltown
World told the source
Prince Harry is reportedly planning a
solo trip to Africa to film a
documentary The anticipated solo trip
may just may be just what Harry needs as
he considers the continent his second
home and a place where he feels the most
like himself revealed the anonymous
source Markle on the other hand has
hired a new agent to help her build her
brand Royal expert Daniela alster told
the portal that Meghan Markle was
looking to establish her own brand and
make millions for the first time they
are truly on Divergent professional
paths she was quoted as saying to the
radar online the couple's real
the couple's relations the couple's
relationship reportedly worsened
worsened after their 20 million dollar
deal with Spotify failed to take off
moreover some financial troubles also
played spoilsport in their relationship
that stressed that stress coupled with
their emotional issues has made their
life a living hell taking time apart on
different continents will hopefully help
them find whatever they need to move on
claim the source the couples deal with
the popular streaming service came to an
end in all talks of a second season of
their podcast archetypes fell through
Harry's proposal to interview Donald
Trump Vladimir Putin Pope Francis and
Mark Zuckerberg puzzled the executive
Executives of Spotify at Spotify as per
reports yeah I mean no none of these
guys are going to interview a guy that's
led by his wife you don't even imagine
Trump's like yes I want to be
interviewed by a female-led house like
come on all right another anonymous
source told the celebrity gossip site
that the air had sold their lavish home
and
Monte Sido California and Harry was
staying elsewhere Harry and Megan got
married in a lavish wedding at St
George's Chapel in Windsor in May 19
2018. this is the thing when women lead
relationships when it's happy wife happy
life we lead you right to destruction
now I don't say this as a woman like I'm
happy about it okay you know when we say
give a hundred percent control and
authority to a man it's not like we're
like Yay but when you look at the
results of all of these couples where
the man follows the wife Adam and Lena
um Will Smith and Jada
now Prince Harry and Megan what are the
results of this women will always try to
expert control over men it is in our
nature it started with Adam and Eve and
if we allow that to take over us we
become bitter resentful and we ruin our
homes
it is something as women we need to
fight against and the thing is the thing
is
you left royalty this woman got him to
leave Roy like can you imagine
your life is paid for now there's
financial troubles what's going on
the marriage is gonna end I really hope
that he like goes back maybe I don't
know I don't know if they'll let him
back but it's like you feel so sad for
him because now as if his wife leaves
he's literally alone he's got nothing so
I I don't even what would you do as the
royal family he's been calling you guys
all racist like I
I don't even know what I would do in
that situation